good morning believe nation today's
message is do it because you love it
over to you Leonel messy or colonic
important for a foodie food to skin the
low mood Chiquito illness you Indian
Tonto said correctly seven toner ganja
you break a window my cancer is with a
low or no meteor tough one masculine
alone no lawyers have lo hago por que
vota por que siempre fuzzy yellow Nero
Dementors I make these videos because I
love it I help entrepreneurs because I
love it it fuels me it fills my soul it
gives me energy and I love it and the
minute I stop loving it I'm gonna move
on and do something else and I hope you
guys have the courage to one do the
thing that you love even if you don't
know how it's gonna work out even it
doesn't make any sense because you'll
figure out the path as you go as long as
you are in love with it and - if you
stop falling in love with it if your
passions change if you fall out of love
with it have the courage to switch
because a lot of people hang on for too
long because you've sunk too much cost
time energy into something and you don't
have the courage to then sell it or pass
on it give up on it and move on to
something else as long as you are doing
something that does not make you come
alive and you are not deeply passionate
about
you're never gonna build anything great
building great things starts with having
a great passion for what you're doing so
the question that I today is what do you
do because you love it what do you love
to do leave it in the comments below
and I'm gonna join the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of bench pressing
expresso give me